hello everyone what is good happy Monday
how's it going GameSpot life is back
obviously still working from home and
still bringing you back fresh content um
today we're playing more doom eternal to
be completely honest I've been so
addicted to Animal Crossing that it's
been at least like two weeks since I
played last so I'm gonna be super lost
at first however it's gonna be fun it's
fun
we're here to suffer anyways so let's go
ahead and jump into it I actually don't
really remember where I am at with the
story right now so um oh what happened
to my game seconds let me fix the screen
first
but yeah so we're kind of jumping back
into it's been a little while how's it
going Brandon and pinhead and POC and
Junaid and I'm sorry I'm messing up all
the names right now
[Music]
there we go
yeah okay cool so let me know if
everything sounds good so far should be
fine should be fine I have to collect
myself because I know it's gonna be
madness I know that where I had left off
before it was really starting to get it
super difficult I I don't really know
how far I am into the story right now
remember but it's all good let's do this
[Music]
have a great weekend
letting off some steam here
being a scary
yeah you like Joe what is good
you have a good weekend this week all
right
oh my gosh I know where I left off ahead
so many weapons and I never remember use
them all let's try
great
you
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah hopefully so things like
nightmare advance me she got a Wednesday
on yeah seriously my super shock
I forgot to use the grapple
[Music]
No
leave the area
funnel them up here
[Music]
there's someone right there I find it
really hard to believe that was long
[Music]
yeah I just sounds like a sweet spot
service for the grenades on the shotgun
[Music]
movement
for our personnel the mortally
challenged have entered the compound
evacuation is about
purpose
Oh
okay
oops I keep trying to reload
these doors
every to checkpoint I feel like it's so
calm right now and I'm terrified trying
to be more mindful
don't like these small place
oh yeah I mean it's really hot my god
dr. Hayden was convinced come here for
this evacs
nothing with school I'm ready to see the
cosplayers have at it with this game may
I just say that it is all gone Iran for
me personally
[Music]
the slowest of Walled while potential
guy emergency protocols have been
activated please exit the facility now
we uh we don't know how to access his
main cortex it's all alien we couldn't
figure it out
we have to prepare for his care for
extraction we were given specific orders
[Music]
well
this guy looks terrible
it's pretty cool alone oh oh oh there's
a defensive powerhouse fancy clothes and
uses his shotgun sent to faraway
interest FL food event mid-range counter
his attacks if I flash green otherwise
he blocks your shots the Marauder
Marauder is resistant to super weapons
is that so
I mean he's using the super shotgun on
right now what I hate about this is the
second I back out of this this both
gonna be ready to fight me
Oh Marty I got daughters
oh oh okay that's fine I already knew
he's gonna be whipping out the second I
left that screen not for Terry
[Applause]
our personnel the vertically challenged
have entire compound evacuation
all right I don't know the chains almost
fast enough for those moments
Oh
[Music]
ominous warning personnel the worldís
challenge have entered the compound
evacuation she designed
Hey
oh shoot
[Music]
okay clearly takes a few shots trying to
think the best course of action
[Music]
for all our personnel the mortally
challenged that have entered the
compound evacuation is advisor
[Music]
and low
Oh
crazy
I'm
Oh oh crap oh crap oh why didn't up you
all
I'm fight about blood punch oh I was out
of fuel okay
[Music]
warning olara armored personnel the
Morton a cellist has entered the
compound evacuation is about
sometimes the wolf dog comes out and
sometimes they don't already maybe you
just did in
also this bus cheats out our er
personnel the mood coach others have
entered the compound evacuation is
advised
[Music]
yo
[Applause]
that's
No
it just sees the blood the blood oh yeah
I got a Sigma she'd spent this full on
fire old war debts all our personnel the
vertically challenged have entered the
compound evacuation is advised
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
oh come on do it already oh my god
I hate he waited so long to do the green
eyes were bigger than life
I want he shoots all our personnel the
morning to challenge and enter evil that
evacuation is advice
now give me
[Applause]
Wow oh wow all right let me trade the
morning all our personnel the motor to
the challenge has entered the compound
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and I should switch
get my damage but I
this one
[Music]
crap
[Music]
[Applause]
our personnel challenged
[Applause]
Oh No
Oh
Oh
like okay but now that I have the
combination in order personnel the what
we challenged have entered the compound
evacuation it advised
like I'm getting more from
[Music]
[Applause]
do it slow being scared
yes all right thank you guys for the pro
tip
he was scared to do it he knew
straight aren't you study ready
Oh Mike oh that was the last one
we did it thanks to you guys you helped
me out
hmm did I upgrade my weapon I don't even
remember you have now destroyed 68% of
hell's occupying force without the
priests there is and I have lost the
only functional Slipgate - Sentinel
Prime is in the cool of Mars in the lost
city of the death I have marked its
location for you beginning there will
take time
there is no easy
I definitely felt Italy lose games and
they are designed by dr. Samuel story
but if you guys haven't seen it a new
episode of the load-out you guys just
make it out
maybe if Richie has that has the link at
the ready wait right now I've actually
forgotten how to level up my stuff I
really have not upgraded much too much
Animal Crossing and pressing like B and
like to confirm when it should be a
alright let's upgrade some stuff
it's just so awkward on a controller
switching the grenades but it's fine
still have three more points
goodnight emits a second larger
nondamaging explosion of that fault
I see that could be useful
[Music]
No
there we go decision boats
I haven't unlocked the micro missiles
yet
ooh I need one more point for that I
think I'm gonna I'm gonna hold out give
that this shotty here all right let's go
yeah no no hate here you guys know he no
trouble we just having a good time we
are ripping and tearing but also getting
rowdy at the same time
that's just how
[Music]
all the meatballs
so that I can take care of them take his
key card off his chest because he does
not deserve it
that is nobody there so terrified of
them
[Music]
who are you you can't be here
yeah step aside
step aside flip and
your weapon oh my gosh she's on a
mission the entrance to the BFG 10,000
is just across from this facility what
is the action
the power source of the BFG 10,000
should be of interest to pedestrians I
wish that they actually friendly fire
naturally
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fire
wait
my belly
morning fellas
I
I kind of like
I can't handle speed my game is already
really bad though
oh the music I've heard
[Music]
oh no I killed them
I was trying the same volume but he
already died full morning slave threat
level at maximum
see
[Music]
what
boring
[Music]
Oh
one
[Music]
[Music]
BFG
[Music]
warning be LG 10,000 is fire
bigger evil
turning what did I do to myself no oh
thank
oh no wait
Oh
I didn't realize you went up there to us
I jumped out
[Music]
wouldn't be attitude
Oh
oh hey definitely shouldn't a chainsaw
that first guy
well again Oh
before
oh I couldn't even dash away from that
one
all right I'm not going up there
[Music]
Oh
Oh
Oh
Oh
I felt like I was doing so well
[Music]
for me Bobby and actually 10005
well there is
get rid of
kidding
action
I got stuck on that little branch
oh man getting stuck is the worst
[Music]
that is moving constant the 1-series
ribbon once you have located five ten
thousand is high structure
warning BFG 10,000 to survive
Oh No
I
Oh
[Music]
oh no Ron gun
what
that was like the last guy and then I
could focus on him and he had to get oh
dang it
let me set up
[Music]
warning BFG 10,000 is 5
there we go
the weapons swapping is really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
ah
are you serious so I I knit flat my
thigh this was
it's Dunham in a burrito so
invincibility
[Music]
all that one
what
Oh
or I'm just being flustered now look
what it is getting relaxed
[Music]
one
[Music]
chuckling
come on
would be a G 10,000
I'm trying to move
first I have no mini
Oh
[Music]
not nearly as scary one
[Music]
schematic showing the church on the
bridge would be
morning BFG 10,000
[Music]
should've went over there to check first
enos stuttering a little bit
oh I miss it
now I'm playing on PC you think you're
just more comfortable
right now
and not a practice shooters
oh that was a fail
yellow what's good Shawn
are you doing
thanks for tuning in
yeah
oh my crisis days are you he snuck up on
me there I was so focused on the big boy
oh my gosh
again we're gonna make coming from he's
like dropping down from the ceiling or
something I think
where you goin
turn in feedback you know first
well your hurry
[Music]
where is that coming from
where is he oh my god
he killed me too many times and they
were like don't even spawn over there
anymore
oh I hear now
I'm serious that guy doesn't scare me
I'd like to see him try already and I
got like hopefully I want to redeem that
the switch prime cos you know thinking
integrated that control pod contains the
energy source of the BFG ten pounds
[Music]
I wish you can actually control these
[Music]
target
the bomb is set to self-destruct
we should move ahead
[Music]
check out the middle episode of the
load-out bfq all right capable of
killing most demons with a single shot
I like the sound phat
well that was satisfying he reveals the
facility escape pods to get down to the
Mars core but we have no wave platform
I'm not the best center let me make sure
I'm not missing anything over here
[Music]
Wow
okay somehow I made it over here without
using that one now you never know
there's something hiding
[Music]
what soda hereby that's not good
so
Oh
oh my gosh okay first I staying there
and just walking on my dead body tail
I didn't want to drop down that soon
oh my gosh
well they've spotted me
Oh
wait I forgot
oh so fat wait I forgot there I have to
do something special to get rid of the
totem or do I just attack it
[Music]
I know where it is now over there by the
pool
oh crap oh crap the bus
[Music]
sorry
like
oh that's cool
well
Oh
oh I was too close we traded with each
other
[Music]
Oh
Oh
I missed the portal I swear I was right
next to the portal what the crap
[Music]
I don't want to
like they like
Oh
I just don't wanna near the cloud
I knew I should have just pulled on my
shotgun and shot a grenade in his mouth
looks like I might be able to melt them
really quick
the end
I waited through logs to get him he had
just recovered moving stunned oh my gosh
what am I
[Music]
Oh
so great right now
No
favorite
here
[Music]
that's it
not speak
of course
why Michael that why
I'm so bad because the wrong thing goes
to choose I
[Music]
[Music]
sweetly with
okay thanks game
I
yeah
co-op and du Midi fun nicely done
I am NOT gonna do that right now
well I'm not cynical
[Music]
here I want them to make all the toilets
to surface gun bridge granted
that is wet not at all
Jessica in HR and sizing right I've got
all the room
fire it up
is designed to use only approved Owaisi
ammunition
when it's due before I be right
one way to make an entrance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
don't think always jump here be in the
fact that not all the
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
seriously
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like when it's to fight
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
good luck all right
Oh
Oh
fish
Oh
[Music]
whoo okay I wish it was easier to swap
my needs the fact that it's on the d-pad
is so unfortunate all right give this
another shot
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I forgot
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
making progress
Oh
No
oh alright last night last last part
here and then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I will are these super love this stage
is interesting though because it's like
a lot of platforming mixed with which I
kind of felt like up until now
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I got the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh alright they stay on fire long I
remember playing some of the older games
with Ritchie before
Emma Willard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on that was point-blank right in
the face
I mean honestly we're over time already
um so I think that's a good place to end
it thank you guys so much for tuning in
and hanging out fun as always I really
love this game because it's always a
challenge and you know sometimes when
games are too easy
thank you boring and I feel like this
that doesn't happen here ever it's
always a challenge always super fun and
I still need to beat this game actually
I've been obsessed Animal Crossing and
the last time I played this was on
launch so I definitely need to finish it
I feel like I've gotten pretty far so
far so we'll see thank you guys so much
for hanging out and tuning and don't
forget every single weekday at 2 p.m.
Pacific time you can catch us right here
on gamespot live hope you had a good day
happy Monday have a great rest of your
week and we'll see you guys soon so
[Music]